vous voyez des élèves de l'école joseph
françois perrault dans l'arrondissement
saint-michel des élèves qui font
beaucoup de musique
en étudiant or il manque d'argent
on a besoin d'une salle absolument dans
cette es collègues vous savez qu'il
manque d'argent pour tous dans le réseau
de la csdm
résultat leurs questions mais trop polis
terre décidé de faire quelque chose pour
ces jeunes hier un concert bénéfique
ce vendredi à la salle la maison
symphonique de montréal comme midi
emilie un véritable orchestre
symphonique au service d'un
chef-d'oeuvre de notre temps mais
derrière l'élu train de tout jeunes
concertistes la relève d'une institution
qui a 35 ans cette année de ces bonnes
proportions jeunes ont poursuivi leur
carrière qui jouent à l'étranger à qui
sont chez parquet a cinq qui jouent dans
des orchestres
ça fait 21 ans qu éric levasseur
enseigne la musique à l'école joseph
françois perrault ce matin c'est court
d'orchestre avant si dans sa classe
certains deviendront de grands musiciens
le but premier de ce programme de
musique à l'école publique c'est d'abord
de former de meilleurs personne c'est
important justement dans la musique
d'écouté les ordres de peut penser que
ça soit même ne pas penser à sa
performance
victor a choisi la trompette quant à
trompette jour on sait que c'est la trop
petit bisou qui elle a jeté son dévolu
sur le corps français
la sonatt et est quand même différente
des autres cuivres puisse distinguer
pour moi un programme de musique qui
leur permet d'exprimer leur personnalité
un horaire chargé qui les rend heureux
ma tête voir que des jeunes peuvent
s'intéresser à quelque chose pour
s'investir à 100% et être concentré qui
sait donner son maximum
construite à la fin des années 60
l'école joseph françois perrault
accueille maintenant 800 étudiants dans
le programme de musique ce qui en fait
l'un des plus importants campus du genre
en amérique du nord comme la formation
est gratuite
l'école permet à des enfants qui n'en
auraient pas les moyens de devenir
musicien
en lieu et place de ce stationnement les
jeunes rêvent maintenant à une nouvelle
salle de concert la leur est un peu
vétuste
comme vous voyez ici sourcing de notre
série n 2 de l'école n'ont pas
l'illustré non pas des chahids et ils
sont collés de cette façon si donc on
n'a pas les fosses pour accueillir un
arc s ici à joseph françois perrault de
cette envergure
ici à 280 places donc presque autant sur
cinq présentement que mal afin qu'on
sache on envoie toujours à l'extérieur
donc d'aller à l'extérieur c'est
compliqué il ya des frais
supplémentaires pour déplacer les
instruments et des primes instruments la
csdm est bien conscient du problème mais
dans le contexte actuel où une salle
concert pourrait paraître luxe
elle cherche des sources de financement
chez des partenaires privés mais aussi
auprès du gouvernement du québec est
très important pour nous à la csdm
d'investir dans les enfants qui
réussissent moins nous ce sont les
enfants qui réussissent parce qu'un
enfant qui réussit c'est une belle
victoire ce soir
victor a revêtu son toxedo c'est
l'uniforme
alors que ça fait
classe on sent important
se sentir important quand il y attend
d'urgence c'est déjà un bon début dans
la vie
ici me lit du breuil radio canada
montréal
pas maintenant